The next setting I want to talk about in the rendering section
controls Lumen.
If we take a look at the Lumen section,
we'll see that there are a number of things
we can do, such as adjust the reflection method,
change the reflection capture resolution,
and also adjust the software ray tracing mode.
Again, each one of these settings
is going to have a direct effect on how Lumen will work.
And I highly recommend that you test this.
One thing to note that hardware ray tracing is more expensive,
but it will run on a console.
And when you're running hardware ray tracing on a console,
you will need to set your FPS target to 30 instead of 60.